now come to the leader of the smp ian
black
thank you mr speaker can i associate
myself with the remarks of the prime
minister in the murder of shinzo abe a
dreadful event that took place last
weekend can i also thank you mr speaker
for hosting last night the charity
remembering seveniza we should all take
time this week on the 27th anniversary
of the genocide that took place there to
think of the circumstances and the shame
that we were not able to step in and
stop the murder of so many innocent boys
and men and the rape of so many women
and that we must learn the lessons from
that and of course at this time we think
very much of those in ukraine that are
facing a war criminal and make sure that
those responsible are ultimately held to
account for crimes against humanity
mr speaker the tory leadership contest
is quickly descending into toxic race to
the right and it's clear that whoever
wins that race scotland loses
the former chancellor has pledged to
govern like margaret thatcher the
current chancellor is threatening 20
cuts to the nhs and public services and
they're all trying to outdo each other
on an extreme brexit costing the economy
billions
it's the real reason that the prime
minister won't endorse any of these
awful candidates because whoever becomes
the next tory leader will make genjis
khan look like a moderate
hi minister
[Music]
uh well i i i i'm so i i feel a real
twinge mr speaker that this is uh
probably all virtually the last time i
have the opportunity to uh to answer a
question to the
perhaps because he's going over because
i'm going i don't know uh but uh mr
speaker i all i would say to him is that
uh i think that the uh next uh leader of
of my party uh will i want to make sure
that we do everything we can to work
with the uh the scottish government in
the way that i've been able to do i'm
proud to have done over the last uh a
few years to protect and secure our
union and
my strong view mr speaker having
listened to him very carefully uh for
years and years now is that we are much
much better together
in blackfoot i can say with all
sincerity i hope whoever is the next
tory leader will be as popular in
scotland as he has been
[Applause]
for people in scotland
westminster has never looked so out of
touch we've got right-wing tory
contenders prioritizing tax cuts for the
rich and a zombie uk government failing
to tackle the cost of living crisis
while satoris are busy tearing lump outs
of each other money-saving expert martin
lewis has warned the energy price cap
could soon rise by a sickening 65 in
october to 3 244 pounds a year after a
decade of tory cuts and brexit price
rises it will mean many families simply
can't afford to put food on the table
and heat their homes scotland literally
can't afford the cost of living with
westminster does the prime minister not
get that people in scotland don't just
want rid of him they want rid of the
whole rotted westminster system
like minister
mr speaker i actually i think that's not
what is actually happening in this
country is that we're using the the
fiscal fire power that we built up to to
cut taxes uh for for working people cut
taxes for those on low incomes and you
saw that last week uh in the 300 average
of 330 pound uh tax cut of on national
insurance we're increasing support for
those uh vulnerable households from
tomorrow another 326 pounds going in uh
mr speaker it's thanks to our union uh
that we were able to uh we were able to
deliver uh the furlough scheme which
helped uh the entire country and uh to
make the
massive transfers uh that boost the
whole of the uk economy and i think uh
that the people who's the last thing
that people in scotland need now uh and
the nasty the people
the last thing they need is more
constitutional wrangling uh when uh we
need to fix the economy